[Music]
for many this was undisputed proof the
prison system is in crisis riots
breaking out at HMV Bedford in November
a month later
spreading to Birmingham hundreds of
prisoners were involved in the
disturbances they followed repeated
warnings about low staffing levels
[Music]
finally the government seems to be
waking up it aims to recruit 2,500 extra
officers to help staff at 31 prisons in
the southeast will see their pay rise by
up to 5,000 pounds thanks to a 12
million pound cash injection at HMP temp
side in southeast London inmates had
some ideas of their own about how to
improve the system a lot more I think a
lot more stuff in what is being proposed
and I think that will make a huge
difference you know it's not going to
actually clean up the streets of crime
but I think it'd make it make a massive
difference to the way people are
processed you know and progress for the
system the world another government
notoriously bad for employing people
when they leave prison are probably the
first thing they say it says on an
application form
it's do you have a criminal record and
you probably won't even get past the
first stage of an interview so something
like that needs to be addressed and we
definitely need to give ex-offenders a
chance especially having been here now
for two years
unfortunately I've seen a lot of young
people I've come back already something
even twice and even that for me is very
very difficult to see in this circuit on
jail prisoners are learning printing
skills to help cut reoffending and
improve their job prospects no wonder it
was the location chosen by justice
secretary Liz trust to announce her new
initiative we are doing a huge amount of
practical things we're investing in
2,500 prison officers across the
prisoners state that will mean that we
have one officer for every six offenders
helping them and encouraging them to
turn their lives around we're also
dealing with the issues of drugs drones
and things but it is incredible
important that we all agree the purpose
of our prisons is of course about
punishing people people have done wrong
but it is also about reforming people
and that's never been agreed before and
what this will also do is give the
prison inspector new teeth so he is able
to say if the prison is succeeding at
that or if it's failing and if it's
failing the Secretary of State I mean
we'll have to act and that is really
important that's the first time the
prison inspector will have those teeth
you mentioned there 2,500 extra prison
opposites now that's replacing half of a
total that have been lost since 2010
this happened admission that the last
government went too far in cuts to
prisons well things have changed over
the last six years we've got a higher
proportion of people in prison for
violent crime sex crime and drug supply
we've also got different prisons so
we've got more digital presence among
inmates where difficulty fall but what I
think we faced at the time was an
increase in psychoactive substances and
increase in phones and drones and we
don't have and I've been clear about
that we don't have enough staff to be
able to deal with those challenges so
what I'm doing is I'm putting those new
staff in we're also making sure those
staff are deployed in the right way is
what's important is we have people on
the wings who were there who are fully
trained up who are skilled we can
encourage those people to turn their
lives around now and part of your
announcement as well is more money some
prison offices now at the same time
there was nearly six and a half thousand
assaults in prisons last year head of
the proven person office Union warned
that it was a bloodbath it's a bit of
extra money really gonna help recruit
more people to what is very difficult
profession it is tough for prison
officers and I go round prisons around
the country they are fantastic people
who are in the job for all the right
reasons and that's why I want to make
sure they're properly rewarded for the
work they do that they've got good
training and progression so we're
creating new jobs in the service as well
at a higher level in the organization so
people can earn more money for specific
skills like the ability to deal with
to health issues for example but what
we're particularly doing is in areas
like London and the south east giving up
a boost for new recruits so you'll be
able to join on a starting salary of
about thirty thousand pounds if you join
the Prison Service now of course it's a
tough environment to recruit in I
recognize that we're not going to turn
our prison around in weeks or months it
takes time to train people bring new
people on it's been difficult time
recently for presidents we've had riots
that were the worst in decades suicides
are at a record number assaults in
prison or at a record number is the
prison system in a crisis we're in a
very difficult situation I have
absolutely Center that is true but I
don't believe the council of despair the
people around that are saying this can't
be solved it can't be worked out we've
got some fantastic examples of good
things that are happening our prison
here at HMP temp side we've got a great
print workshop we can see people are
learning they're going to get the skills
they need to do jobs on the outside what
we need to do is make sure that's
happening across our system that's where
we need a much better framework to make
the purpose of prison clear as well as
being that punishment is also about
reform and that's why we need those
officers there's clearly good examples
of what's happening in prisons but at
the same time there are also some pretty
worrying examples as well when you have
prison officers walking out because they
say they feel unsafe that sounds like a
crisis doesn't it it is a very difficult
situation we're in what we're announcing
today is additional funding for those
prison officers we're announcing new
positions for more senior prison
officers I want to see a
professionalized prison service where
people have good career development good
training all of these things take time
but we're moving in the right direction
the UK locks people up at a higher rate
than any other country in Western Europe
it's a simple fact that we're actually
just incarcerated too many people
well if you compare us internationally
we look up far fewer people than the US
we look up fewer people in Australia so
we're roughly mid-table in terms of the
number of people we lock up and over the
last six years the prison population has
remained stable at about 85,000 what's
actually happening is we're locking up
more people for crimes like sex crime
and we're prosecuting more people for
those crimes and we're actually looking
fewer people up for crimes like
shoplifting so after over the last six
years we locked up 3,000 more sex
offenders but the overall prison
population didn't go up and you know I
think it's right that this the sentences
for sex offending has gone up by 50% and
you're comfortable then with the other
people I think the fact is that in the
80s and 90s we were not putting people
in jail for long enough for serious sex
crimes for issues like child abuse and
we weren't prosecuting enough people to
often the victims were on trial rather
than the perpetrators that has now
changed we've seen a hundred and forty
percent increase in the amount of sex
criminals who are prosecuting and
bringing to justice that has
consequences for our jail population
over time I want to see us reduce
reoffending so we're not having the same
people going in and out of our jails I
want to see us intervene earlier to stop
these horrible crimes being committed
but I do think that if somebody has
committed a serious crime and we know
that three-fifths of the people in our
jails have committed serious sexual
violent or drug supply offenses then yes
we should be putting them in jail and I
do not support the idea that we're going
to solve the problems in our prisons
simply by letting those people out early
into society we need to solve the
problem by reforming those people why
there are no prisons so they don't
commit those crimes again and that is
absolutely doable it's absolutely
possible so your predecessor Michael
Gove said it's an inconvenient truth
that we send too many people to prison
but you're saying that he's wrong I'm
not saying he's wrong at all what I'm
saying is the best way to send fewer
people to prison is to make sure that
while people
prison they're doing things that are
productive they're doing things that
will help turn their lives around so
they're less likely to reoffend we're
seeing fewer people going into prison
for the first time which is a big
success but our reoffending rates are
sky high say that they're going in and
out of the system and that is the
problem that I'm seeking to address but
what I'm saying is there is no quick fix
to this
we can't just suddenly let out those
sexual offenders or violent offenders
early I think that would be the wrong
approach instead we have to make sure
our prisons are focused on reforming
them so we don't have those people going
back into prison the big legal story
that came into your in-tray so far of
course was when the Supreme Court
decided that Parliament should have a
say over article 50 now you were
criticized for not backing the judges
strongly enough and quickly enough when
they received the storm of attacks in
the media and from elsewhere on social
media as well if you went back would you
have acted a bit quicker to support the
justice justice well I have consistently
stood up for the judiciary I'd already
made statements before that my swearing
in as Lord Chancellor I made clear about
my belief in the rule of law and how
vital it is but I do think it's very
dangerous if politicians start
commenting on newspaper headlines and
telling the press what it's acceptable
to print or what it's acceptable not to
print my job as Lord Chancellor is to
uphold the rule of law and uphold the
independence of the judiciary these are
traditions and institutions that been
going for over a thousand years and I
think it's wrong to suggest that a few
newspaper headlines are the problem well
even when the president the Supreme
Court says that politicians could have
been quicker and clearer in the defense
what I'd say about the president is him
preme Court is he's a great individual I
think the Supreme Court came out very
well from the increased public scrutiny
that it received and it was good for
people to understand how the Supreme
Court operates what the role of the
judiciary is and it's good that he is
going out there and explaining the role
of the judiciary because I think too
many people in our country don't
understand
what judges do what the role of the
judiciary is in the Constitution which
is we've got a sovereign Parliament but
their role is interpreting interpreting
the law and I think it's really
important that in the modern age where
more of us are under scrutiny whether
you're a captive industry or a
politician or a judge that judges
themselves are out there explaining what
they do I think that's really positive
you've been quite passionate in your
defence there of the kind of justice
system so how does it make you feel to
see the man in the white house attacking
some of the legal decisions that be made
I think what we're seeing in the u.s. is
again a very robust Constitution that
has separation of powers and we're
seeing you need the judges the judges
involved in that the president involved
in that and we see you uncomfortable
with Donald Trump's attacks from there
why didn't we see a constitution in
action and what what what is being
shamed there is the limits of
presidential power and the fact that
they do have a strong independent
judiciary in the u.s. it almost feels as
though with every day that goes by of
Donald Trump's presidency that decision
by the UK to cozy up to him to befriend
him is looking increasingly risky and I
completely disagree with that I
completely disagree with that these are
our most important international allies
of course we should work with the u.s.
of course we should so you're
comfortable then to see us going over
there inviting him to have a state visit
inviting him to meet the Queen you don't
think there's risks to that absolutely
and the u.s. is vital our partnership
with the US and in fact Europe's
partnership with the u.s. is vital for
our economy it's also vital for our
security and I think the Prime
Minister's work in securing that
agreement on NATO was really really
important there were there were big
there were big issues there were big
threats in the world that we face at the
moment and it's important that countries
work together of course we didn't agree
with everything that happens in the US
as actually we don't agree with make
sure a lot of things that don't happen
in other countries but that doesn't mean
that we shouldn't work together of
course it doesn't